yeah that's the
that's the right one okay let me try and
get back on the horse here
oh knight c6 i thought he was playing
the dragon
okay i'll go knight c3 though
h4 the first opportunity
gotta gotta play aggressively
and now i started playing not so
aggressively but that's okay
it's just playing so fast
it's a new challenge
so he's clearly not scared
when it comes to
what i have going on the king side but
now i think he gave me a lot of central
control
never he goes e5
yeah i see the bar but i don't see how i
can close it
frankly i don't have time for that
okay let me
get rid of some some material here
i feel like this should be pretty
favorable favorable for me
so apparently there is a problem but i
gotta
i mean i gotta finish the game cannot do
anything about it
until then yeah so bishop b5 is an issue
um
yeah 96 looks like we should have
very good compensation d5 96 coming next
but he's tricky he's gonna fight it's
not gonna lie down
yeah apparently i was told to
shut the picture down so that's what i'm
gonna do
anyway the game is proceeding quite
favorably for me i think
should be completely
winning by now
okay gotta be a bit careful
yeah i'll just go and take g6 while i
have a chance 95
is obviously impossible because it
quickly fine i also threatened e5 i was
not so sure about the immediate e5 and
then you could go reach d5
now i should be alright queen g7 is a
huge threat as well
so i'll just take
[Music]
take again e5
e6 is the big threat
so he wants to go rook t5 after e6
i guess i should take button most of all
i got
oh i completely missed that he can go
queen b7
playing so badly he has bishop d5 now
and then
i'm not sure i have so much
can i go kh2 i'm not sure
okay
starting to look like a w for me
okay it's just gonna sit out
okay one for me